[MUSIC  PLAYING]
HANS DOCKTER: I had a
funny incident last night.
I went back to the hotel,
and then went to my room,
put in the room card,
and nothing happened.
I said, did I forget
my room number?
I tried out a few other rooms
and it was completely weird.
What is going on?
So I went down to the
reception and said,
either the card is broken
or I forgot my room number.
She said, let me see your card.
No, you're in the wrong hotel.
[LAUGHTER]
Go down, your one
is down the street.
It's the one further down.
I said, OK.
So it's not to even
finished, the story.
Then I went to the other hotel.
I said, well, it
looks really similar.
And I met a friend
of mine I haven't
seen for while-- I
just told her the story
you know what happened to me?
So we went up to the second
floor and we said goodbye,
and then she went to her room,
well, she went to my room
and put her room
card on my room door.
I said-- and then she
was in the wrong hotel.
[LAUGHTER]
And she was in the
one I was before.
So that's the Hampton
and the Holiday Inn.
That was really funny.
Deep dive into the
Gradle-based Android
build system-- I'm Hans Dockter.
I'm the founder of Gradle
and the CEO of Gradle Inc.
And I want to talk about
Android build system,
the deep concepts behind
the Android Build System,
and why it is created that way.
Let's start.
So what are the goals of
the Gradle Android-based
build system?
I think it is very
important to understand,
as an educated Android
developer, what
are the qualities, what
are the deeper design
goals of that build system.
Even if you use it
from Android Studio,
still it's, I think,
important to understand
and also when you compare
it with other platforms.
And it's also interesting
to see how we are actually
doing in reality in
regard to our lofty goals,
or not so lofty.
We'll see.
So the first thing
to understand,
Android is a complex platform,
not quite as complex as C, C++,
but way more complex than Java.
So when you look
at this diagram,
even if you can't
read what is in there,
this is the workflow building
an Android application.
And you all know that you
have complex, resource,
and code generation.
You don't have that in Java.
You have multiple
different languages.
You have the NDK.
You have Java.
You have the interface
definition languages.
And so there's lots going on.
You have to sign in.
You have the dexing
plus the compiling,
and so on, and so on.
So the original
Java tools that were
used to build the
Android apps are not
made for that complexity.
There was Ant,
there was Eclipse,
and there was, for quite
a few people, Maven.
So they're already hitting
their limit in Java land
and they were not
made for Android.
And I talked about it, ran the
script, and the native code
and whatnot.
But there's another
challenge in Android land.
I call it platform diversity.
Others call it fragmentation.
And this has been one of
the biggest pain points
for developers to deal with.
I just want to have
a little variation
of my app for that platform.
And it was very hard to
implement with the build system
at that time.
So how to make this diversity
approachable from a developer
tooling perspective was a key
goal for the new build system.
I forgot my transitions.
OK, here we go.
So what makes Gradle
unique and what
is harnessed by the
Gradle Android plugin
is that you have
the expressiveness
to model the
complexity, that you
have really concise
descriptions of your
build, that something
may even was doing
a reasonable job in Java land.
So that is a strength of Gradle.
At the same time, Maven is
concise for simple use cases,
but can't go beyond that.
Ant, or other similar design
systems like a Facebook Buck
or whatnot, they
are very flexible,
but they expose a level of
complexity to developers
and build master that
is, at one point,
very expensive to manage.
And Gradle tries to
combine the conciseness
of a declarative good
language like Maven
without sacrificing the
power and the flexibility
and the extensibility that
you have with Ant and Ivy.
In fact, done right,
if you combine it,
you get even better
extensibility.
Now, we'll talk
about that later.
OK, so to give you an example
of what I mean with conciseness,
look at this very simple build
definition for a standalone
Android app-- a
few lines of code.
You have two product
flavors-- two dimensions.
And for each dimensions,
you have two flavors.
For the version, you have
a free and a paid version.
For the ABI, you
have arm and x86.
And you could now do
certain definitions.
What you can already do when
you have such a definition,
you can put code in Source
Free or test in Source Free
or in Source Page or in
Source ARM or Source 86.
And Android knows
exactly-- the Android build
system, what to do with that.
It runs the free test only
when you build the free APK.
So that is a reasonably
simple problem.
And this is how it is expressed.
So can you read that
in the last row?
No, I'm joking.
So when you do, for this
little build script,
when you do Gradle tasks--
so all of the tasks
that Gradle creates
to build this,
you have more than 300 tasks.
So imagine how the Ant
build would look like.
It would be 1,000 lines of XML.
With Maven, on the
other hand, it's
completely impossible to
model this within one project.
Maven would tell
you, well, you need
to separate sub-project per
flavor, per test per flavor.
You would end up
with a sub-project,
30 multi-module Maven
build or something
like that, which is
also kind of, hey,
I'm an Android developer.
I have a little requirement--
certain variance
I want to express around
my simple Android app.
And now I end up with a 20,
30 sub-module Maven build.
That's not what you
want to be challenged
with as an Android developer.
So that gives you kind of an
idea what has been a shift.
So the key mission
is accomplished.
There is now a
powerful Android build
system with which you can
elegantly describe many
of the typical requirements.
You have one building Android
applications, including
kick ass dependency management.
It has the right mixture between
flexibility and structure.
When you just have
flexibility, you
might have a lower
complexity to deal
with as an Android developer.
But if you have just
structure and no flexibility,
you can't extend the things.
So this is a really
nice mixture.
And it's a true achievement
by the Google Android
team, who is maintaining and
creating the Gradle Android
plugin, to have modelled the
functional domain of building
Android so well, based, of
course, on the capabilities
of Gradle.
And there's more to come.
So the foundation is rock solid.
And the feedback
we're getting is
that people are very
happy with that aspect.
And I haven't talked
about performance yet.
And I want to talk about
something else first.
So some other goals that
are behind the system.
It is not good enough for most
Android developers to just
have a good Android build.
You have back end services
written in Java, C++, Ruby.
You have other
libraries to deal with
and potentially written
other languages.
And you want to be able to
integrate deeply with those
during development cycles.
You don't want to be
the isolated Android
team like it is still today
in so many organizations.
The Android teams are isolated
from the continuous delivery
process of the rest of the
team, and that is not good.
The people writing
the back end services
should be able to
ask the question,
is this change breaking
the Android app?
And that is often not possible,
but with Gradle, you now
have the tool to have a really
unified build experience.
And Gradle is a powerful,
polyglot build system with
strong support for
C, C++, and Java,
also for Python and interesting
wrapping around the JavaScript
ecosystem.
So Linked In is a very
good example for that.
LinkedIn has an
armada of languages.
It all builds with Gradle
in one or the other way
with 40-plus languages.
Some are very exotic,
all built with Gradle,
either with a direct
implementation, or with Gradle
like with Python adding
some functionality
on top of the existing
Python food chain.
They've also integrate a Hadoop
developer tooling around it.
So that is a big benefit you
get if you work in a team.
If you're not just
writing Android,
you have now a build
system that can
integrate all the different
pieces much better.
To give you an idea of
the scope, how Gradle
is used in some
organizations, at LinkedIn,
it is used by 2,000 engineers,
and they have 300,000 Gradle
build executions per week.
So the biggest Gradle build
has 3,800 sub-modules.
And one other thing that is
interesting with LinkedIn--
like more and more
organizations,
they switched from teams
that have been created
around technology-- the
Android team, the iOS team--
to functional teams--
so teams that share
the back end and
the different UIs
and apps that are
developed around a set
of functionalities.
So now for them, it's
even much more important
to have a build
system that wraps
around the whole
functional team,
even though they're using
very different languages.
For a talk about
performance, extensibility.
It is not just good
enough to solve
the standard requirements,
even in a polyglot setting.
So you've got a lot of
out-of-the-box stuff from
Gradle, and so the
example projects all work.
But people that are ambitious
about developer productivity
and automation and/or work
in a more complex environment
desperately need extensibility.
So with the new
build system, you
are able to inject
custom steps anywhere.
You have deep APIs with
listener frameworks
to get into the guts of
the system if needed.
Even in the test
execution, you can
hook in a listener with Gradle.
Hey, send me an
event after you've
executed the test method.
I want to do something with
it, whatever that may be.
Maybe you have a fragile test
you want to do deal with.
And you say, oh, this
test I need to run again
to make sure that it has
really failed, whatnot,
whatever pathologies you need
to embrace as part of your work.
And their are powerful
features to integrate
deeply any other technology
tool chain into your build.
And it's not just extensible.
You can extend it in a way
that your build stays concise.
You can extend to create
a declarative language
with your own declarative
language element
to make it very easy for
your developers to work
with your custom requirements.
And even if you say,
oh, extensibility
is not important for me,
well, in an indirect way,
it is because you
will benefit from it
by a very powerful
plugin ecosystem that
depends on this extensibility.
And there are really interesting
Android plugins out there.
If you create a
run so extensible,
the plugins wouldn't
be so powerful.
So even if you
don't extend it, you
have a more powerful
plugin ecosystem
out there of greater
plugins that you can use.
I always forget my transitions.
OK, so Gradle is a very strong
foundation for the Android
build system.
It is a built platform
with massive traction.
We had just crossed the
one million downloads
per month line in September.
It's evolving very fast.
We have 19 feature releases
in the last three years,
and we get a large amount of
contributions from individuals
and organizations like LinkedIn,
Netflix, Google, Android, Unity
Technologies, and many more.
So a lot of innovation
is happening,
and Gradle is a generic
automation platform.
For whatever you want to
automate, you can use it.
Because as a developer,
you're not just creating APKs.
You are shipping software
with a group of people,
which is a much larger scope.
You might want to have
auto-provisioned def
environments.
You might want to generate
documentation for client API
that you are shipping where all
code snippets are integration
tested.
That's how we ship
our documentation.
Every snippet in the Gradle
user guide is life tested.
While we are creating
the user guide,
we run the integration
test, right,
against the snippet in there.
Then we extract the output
of the integration test
and insert it into
the user guide
to make sure that we don't have
the money for an editorial team
or don't want to
spend it on that
and still want to give you a
high-quality documentation.
So when you really think
about shipping software,
there's so many tasks
you can automate.
And once you have a system
that allows you to do that,
you can get really creative.
You want to have a fully
automated release process.
You might want to have
central version strategies
for the libraries
you're consuming,
automated database migrations,
container integration
for certain integration tests.
How to deal with fragile
tests-- a big problem
we see in many organizations.
When you have a build
system that says,
well, you can only have
one group of tests,
and when some of them
are fragile tests,
it usually means
people start ignoring
if this test suite fails.
It says, ah, yeah, OK, it might
be interesting that it fails.
It might be not.
So with Gradle, you
could easily isolate
and say, OK, there
are non-fragile tests
are put in that group.
And they are really part of my
continuous delivery pipeline.
If the CI is failing here,
everyone stops work and fix it.
And then there is the other
group of tests, fragile,
the menu will test
us-- might still use
them to get some indications.
But I don't want to rely on
them for my automated pipeline--
stuff like this.
Or you have very time-consuming
pseudo-integration tests
where you want to
maybe separate them
into DP integration tests,
UI integration tests
so that you get faster feedback.
People that work
on a database only
want to execute the
DB integration tests
before they commit
because they don't
want to wait another hour.
So there's a lot of
interesting stuff in the domain
of continuous delivery.
It's a complex domain.
Gradle is your friend.
So be ambitious about automating
your whole shipping process.
So let's look at
an example of some
of the nice features of
how Gradle can help you
in getting better into
the flow and achieving
a high degree of automation.
So what we have here is, oops,
is an Asciidoctor project.
So let's look at this.
So it's built with Gradle.
Who of you knows Asciidoctor?
Asciidoctor is a markup language
more complex than Markdown.
It's kind of
replacing the DocBooks
and the LaTex of the world.
So O'Reilly is using Asciidoctor
only since a couple of years,
I think, for their books.
And so there's a Gradle
Asciidoctor plugin out there.
Let's look at the project.
We have a source
main Java directory
so it's a Java project.
And with Asciidoctor, we
create a manual for that.
Can you see that, by the way?
We create a manual
for this Java library.
And example-manual is the
source file for the manual.
So let's look at
the source file.
So here you see the Asciidoctor
annotate or markup language.
And we can now tell Gradle,
hey, turn this into a HTML page.
So we did that.
Now we open the
HTML page, and you
see this Asciidoctor document
now rendered in HTML.
So let's change the source
file, the Asciidoctor file.
Let's do something exciting.
Let me go back to
the command line.
We build it again.
We refresh.
I don't expect you
to be excited yet.
So now we do something exciting.
We run the Asciidoctor task
in the Gradle continuous mode,
--continuous.
And what you can see
now, now Gradle listens.
Now, Gradle listens
to any changes.
So if we now go back
to the document, that's
something really
exciting, and we save it,
we don't need to rebuild.
We just do a refresh,
and it's updated.
And, of course, we can continue
to do that, continuous mode
introduced with Gradle 2.5.
And we are super
excited about that.
So we save it again.
We do a refresh, and here we go.
And yeah, and you can now see
the changes were detected,
so the builds were executed.
And the interesting
thing, I mean,
it's not the first
time that there is
a watch solution on the market.
For people doing
Ruby, they had that.
The special thing here is you
don't need to specify anything.
Usually all the
watch solutions you
need to specify some glob
patterns, where to look for,
and what to do if
that pattern changes.
Gradle knows all that.
We have a rich
input-output model.
You just say run this
task in continuous mode,
and Gradle knows
exactly for what
changes to look because the
input and outputs are defined
in a Gradle build,
if that makes sense.
So for the developer,
it's super easy.
You can do this with
any Gradle task.
They don't need to
configure anything for this.
And so we use that in
many places internally.
Documentation is a place.
Another place is for our
upcoming gradle.com offering.
Our whole back end app is
using the continuous mode.
We start in continuous
mode, and then
whatever we change in the app
is automatically picked up.
The app is redeployed, and it's
a wonderful, rapid application
development mode.
And think about what that means
from a deeper point of view.
So we had a chat with LinkedIn.
Yes, their goal for next
year is that developers never
need to directly call
the build system.
That is the goal for 2016.
So how are we going
to achieve that?
That is key tool for that.
So they basically will bundle a
preconfigured, continuous mode
settings with the IDE.
So when the developers
fire up the IDE,
they do not just fire up
the JetBrain, IntelliJ.
They fire up a
whole set of rules
that Gradle gets instructed
with what to watch for.
So when you have
some source code
generation, some specific
one, you just fire up the IDE.
It starts the continuous
mode, and your developers
do some changes in, let's say,
the XML configuration file,
and boom, Gradle will
automatically rebuild it.
The developers don't even know.
Is that the IDE doing this?
Is that the build
system doing that?
And the whole thing is the IDE.
It's the whole thing.
And so I'm super excited
about how continuous mode can
basically extend the
capabilities of a classic IDE
because, finally, your IDE
becomes extendable with Gradle.
Which of you has ever written
an Eclipse nature or an Eclipse
builder?
Who wants to do that, right?
And IntelliJ is the same thing.
Build systems are made
for this kind of stuff.
So continuous mode is a super,
super exciting capability.
And I'm sure we will find
interesting opportunities
to integrate that
with Android Studio.
So we already have had
a chat with the guys,
and we will see what
comes out of that.
Talking about Android Studio,
one of the most important goals
of the new Android
developer tool chain
was a true Android IDE
that natively understands
Android projects in
contrast to, let's say,
the Eclipse ADT project,
And the other key goal was
the IDE should build the same
way as the command line NCI,
that you have consistency
and coherent quality
of service of the def tooling.
If you remember, Eclipse ADT
had a separate build system.
You had an Ant build
or a Maven build--
whatever you have chosen.
But when you were
working in Eclipse ADT,
it came with its own tool chain,
own merging, own everything.
That's how you had to do it.
There was no way to
deeply integrate it.
So the goal of
Android Studio was
the IDE is not doing any
actions themselves anymore.
Every action execute task
generate resources and is
delegated to the
underlying greater build so
that whether you execute your
build from the command line
or whether you're just working
Android Studio is exactly
the same behavior.
And so unified
build system, and I
talked about with Gradle you can
now extend your build system.
Let's say you're
working in Android
Studio on some widget that
shows you a quote of the day.
So you could now--
let's say, if it's just
for fun for you developers.
You just use it for the debug,
for the debug build type.
You could now
easily tell Gradle,
hey, I want to hook
in another task
while you are generating
the resources,
and I want you to retrieve
the quote of the day
from some server and edit
to the resources files.
So you just add that task
to your build script.
And if you are working
in Android Studio
because Android Studio instructs
Gradle to create the resources,
you will now have in your
visual design widget,
you will have always a
changing quote of the day.
So you get the point.
It's not fully integrated
with Android Studio
because Android Studios, they're
getting everything to Gradle.
So you can now really
powerfully extend your IDE.
With Eclipse ADT, it would have
been completely impossible--
separate worlds-- what
you do in the build
and what you do in your IDE,
and your IDE is usually not
extendable.
So and the other part
besides being extension aware
is as the Android domain is
deeply modeled in Gradle,
it is easy for Android Studio
to derive rich information
from the build spec.
So if you look at an example,
here we have Android Studio.
So we have two product
flavors, free and paid.
They use different
for whatever reason.
version codes.
They could use
different dependencies.
But that's not what
I want to show here.
And so now we go into
the visual mode, right,
and we can now
change-- I will have
a stiff neck after this talk.
You can now change, because I
don't see that on my screen,
the build variant.
So we choose free release,
and if we switch to pay debug,
that is deep IDE integration.
That's fun.
That's how it should be.
What do I want to show here?
Yeah, I skipped the
whole tooling API topic.
So we have a special library
that we create so that IDEs
can interact with Gradle,
be it Android Studio,
plain IntelliJ, or Eclipse, but
don't need to go into detail.
The only thing that
is interesting--
that's the only thing I would
like to mention-- we ourselves
create the Gradle
plugin for Eclipse
or I should say the Gradle
plugin for the Eclipse plugin
ecosystem to be very clear,
and we only do that for Java.
We are not working on
Android support for Eclipse.
And one thing we have
added that is really nice,
I talked about what a
deep API Gradle has.
What you can now do from Eclipse
is when you go to your package
or to any test class and
you can right click it
and you say execute, you know
all the visual few you then
get that shows you the test
execution, the execution
windows for testing with in IDE.
Classically, the IDEs come
with their own test runners.
So now with Buildship,
you have now
the same visual representation,
a really nice runner that
runs the test, gives you
a green or red button.
But, actually, all the tests
are executed by Gradle,
and with the
tooling API, we hook
into the eventing system of
Gradle and a really nice, rich
representation.
At the same time, it's
no longer that Eclipse
has a separate test
execution than Gradle.
And think about what that
means for integration tests.
I have been in many
organizations that
told the developers if you
want to execute integration
tests from your IDE, you
have to go to the build wiki.
And before you integrate
your integration tests,
you have to go to
the command line
and execute with your Gradle
and Maven build, fire up
the database, create test
data, some manual step,
and then you can run the
integration test from Eclipse
because you couldn't
extend Eclipse
to do this kind of stuff.
Now with Gradle, all
these test features set up
is implemented in Gradle.
So if you now can
run, your tests
executed by Gradle
from an IDE, you
don't need to go
to any build wiki.
The developers don't care.
They just say run my test
and Gradle makes sure
that all your tests
features are properly
set up because it's extensible.
So to wrap this up, I
want to look a little bit
under the hood of
certain core concepts.
So this is the plugin that tells
Gradle, hey, this is an Android
application.
And we call that a
declarative element.
I will talk about that in a
second, what we mean by that.
So first of all, it constitutes
certain conventions.
If you tell Gradle these
are Android applications,
we say if you then put certain
things in certain places
like the source
code and the tests
as defined by the
conventions, you
don't need to specify anything.
And just by those few
lines of code and sticking
to the conventions,
Gradle will provide you
all the tasks that are necessary
to deal with this application.
So that's what we define
as a declarative element
in the build script.
The declarative element
in the build script
is something that
specifies the what.
This is an Android application.
The how is automatically
figured out for you by Gradle.
We call this the
executional units that every
build system has.
You don't need to
specify the [INAUDIBLE].
And it's fully imperative.
You, as a build
author, or as someone
that specifies the
build-- with Ant,
you have to do all the
specifications directly
via the executional
units by the targets.
With Gradle, you have
declarative elements,
and the executional
units are derived.
So then you can run the
sample debug and whatnot.
So the interesting
thing-- and this
is where Gradle goes way
beyond other declarative
build systems-- you have
very fine grained declarative
elements-- so build types,
you can specify release type,
or we have the product
flavors where you can specify
free and paid product flavors.
And those are not simple.
This is not like simple
configuration actions
what you're doing.
You are really using new
declarative elements.
What do I mean with that?
When you specify I have
a free product flavor,
you trigger a whole
little mini framework.
When you specify
the free flavor,
Gradle will automatically
create a number of tasks
to deal with this free
flavor-- assemble the free APK
or the resource
generation, the test task
that only executes the
test for the free flavor.
You have a certain set
of conventions in place.
If you now put code
in source free,
it will be
automatically picked up.
So this is a very
powerful element.
And after adding the fact
that you have a free flavor,
you can see all the tasks
that are automatically
created as part of that.
So for us, declarative elements
are a very important concept
to give you the right
mixture between flexibility
and structure,
high-level declarative
elements that you
can pick and choose
to describe your requirements.
And what is a key goal for us
is that you can describe it
with your domain language.
We don't make you think
like a build system.
You can think like an
Android developer specifying
what you need, and we translate
it into build system concepts,
if you need to do some
really deep customization.
Yes, you need to understand
the build system,
but not for your normal work.
OK, finally, performance.
So let's talk about the
Gradle core performance,
unrelated to Android, just
the Gradle performance as a
build system.
Gradle is a very
fast build system.
So if you look at
Java and you execute,
let's say, a 25
sub-module Java build,
you just say, hey, clean and
create me all the JARs of that.
And I think with the
latest Gradle versions,
it will be under two seconds.
You can do it in parallel.
So with the latest
Gradle versions,
it will be under one second.
And if you do incremental
mode, you know what I mean.
And we always continue
to work on that.
This is now a 200
sub-module build.
And even that, if you
do a full, clean build,
it's not strictly slow.
And again, we have
improved that even
since I did the recordings.
So seven seconds for
a 200 sub-module build
with a lot of code is fine.
We are working with some
very large software stacks.
And they have extraordinary
performance requirements,
and our goal is
to be the fastest
build system in the world.
And especially for
those large teams,
to bring them finally
into the agile land.
When you have to wait for one
hour until your build finishes,
you can't do agile development.
And the LinkedIn
build time got down
when we're creating from Ant
to Gradle from five hours
to 30 to 40 minutes.
It's still too long.
We want to get it
down under a minute.
We want to get there
with distributed builds
and stuff like that.
There's a lot of
stuff we want to do.
We want to be insanely fast,
even for very large projects.
But the key message
here is-- but even
if we had all those
capabilities already in Gradle,
that wouldn't remove the
major bottlenecks with Android
build performance that
you're facing nowadays.
So let's look at the
Android tool check.
Oh, I will show that later.
So you have Android.
It's good to be aware
of those layouts.
You have the Gradle
Java performance.
It's very different from the
Gradle Android performance.
One reason is that
the Java compiler
is very fast, whereas the
dexing is not quite as fast.
If the Java compiler
were 10 times faster
and the Gradle builds were
10 times faster than Java,
you shouldn't praise us.
You should praise Oracle,
Java C Team right?
So we integrate with
low-level tool chains
as is also the
case with Android.
So if you have bottlenecks in
Android tooling, it's nothing.
We don't maintain those tools.
We can just use them.
At the end of the
day, I understand
that you want fast
builds, and that's
what we will achieve
more and more.
But it's still important
to understand that.
So you have the Android
tooling maintained
by the Android Platform Team.
You have the Gradle
platform maintained by us.
Android plugin maintained
by the Android
Tooling Team, and you
have Android Studio
IDE, also maintained
by the Android Tooling Team.
Android Studio is usually never
the source for any bottlenecks.
It's the three layers
below Android Studio that
have been improved
a lot, but we will
continue to improve
that you will
have a very fast experience.
But still, it's interesting
to understand that there
are different layouts.
So all of those teams, they
are working closely together
to achieve that goal, and they
are all doing a great job,
and it's just that you
can't solve everything
at the same time.
It was a lot of work to
introduce the new system.
It's a massive--
including a new IDE.
So certain optimizations
will follow up later,
and they are now all
a work in progress.
So let's talk about the
Gradle, and by the way,
this was just a tweet today
from Gradle 2.4 to 2.8.
Incremental builds went
down from 10 seconds
to 5 seconds on one
project and 20 seconds
to 11 seconds on another.
So always remember to upgrade
to the latest Gradle versions.
We did a lot of improvements
at the moment coming
with every release,
and we release
every four to six weeks.
And use the Gradle
demon if you are
building from the command line.
OK, let's not talk about that.
So let's look at some numbers--
how things have improved.
So let's ignore 1.2/2.2.1.
So you see the big improvements
we have for let's say a 10
Android-- pretty big Android
build-- 10 sub-projects, 10
variants per sub-project.
s We got the build time
down significantly.
This is now pretty extreme.
One Android project
with 400 variants.
So if you're not
on Gradle 2.4, that
is the minimum you
should be at because that
had dramatic performance
improvements.
So let's talk about the
existing bottlenecks.
So what I use as my Guinea
pig is the Google IO Android
app from 2014.
It's on GitHub.
It's open source.
So it's a nice Guinea pig.
It is pretty representative.
It has a bunch of open
source libraries it's using
and whatnot.
So when you look where
the time is going,
if you do a clean install-- at
the end of the day, what you're
interested in is as the
developer, you do some changes,
and then you want
to see the changes.
Either you want to run your
instrument tests, which
require an install,
or you want to work
with the deployed application
on your virtual device.
So you see the big
bottlenecks are
dexing and pre-dexing
and installation.
That is where, I don't
know, 90% of the time
is going-- when you do a
clean install-- when you move
everything and you build again.
So I want to talk a little
bit about the pre-dexing.
So the libraries your Android
project depends on also
need to be dexed, not just
your compiled source code.
And this is done during
the pre-dex step.
And the Google Android plugin
caches the dex libraries
so that the next time
you run the build, dexing
will be much faster.
But if you do a clean build,
this cache is always deleted,
and all the libraries you depend
on needs to be pre-dexed again.
And if you look at
this, pre-dexing
takes the longest time.
So clean builds are
heavily penalized,
if you like, or first
builds because pre-dexing,
all the libraries you are
using takes such a long time.
What we want to do over the
next three to six months
is a couple of things.
First of all, the
pre-dexing of your libraries
is not happening in parallel.
So when you have 15 libraries,
one is dexed after the other.
The other thing that is
something we want to improve.
We want to put your pre-dexed
libraries into a cache that
survives a clean.
Sometimes you need
to do a clean,
and then when you always
have to have the pre-dexing,
it's a pain in the neck.
So we want to basically
put the pre-dexed libraries
into our library cache that
will survive the clean.
So this kind of cache that
is much more long-lived,
we want to use for those
pre-dexed libraries.
Of course, we have to store
the version of the dexing tool
chain so that if you upgrade
to new dexed version,
we don't want to use
this cached version.
So we need to have a
reliability in there.
But that is something
we will work on.
So that means the
pre-dexing will
become faster because
we'll paralyze it,
and it will survive a clean.
So you will have to
do it much less often.
So pre-dexing-- that is how
it is going to be addressed.
And what we also are going
to start working on next year
is a distributed cache.
This means I talked about that
we put the pre-dexed libraries
into a cache on your local
machine that survives a clean.
The next step is to put it
in a cache that can be shared
with all your developers.
So if one developer has
already pre-dexed the library,
then get it.
Don't do it again.
Or you see iBuild has
already done that, get it.
All those sources will
feed the distributed cache
with build output.
And then other members of the
team don't need to rebuild it,
which means if you are not
just a one person team,
if you have 10, 50 people,
or let's say even 10 people,
in the CI server it means
you will hardly ever
have to wait for pre-dexing
once this is implemented.
So caching, pre-dex
libraries across clean builds
and paralyzing
pre-dexing will cut
the amount developers need
to wait for pre-dexing
by an order of magnitude.
So that's good news.
Those are the things
we want to do.
So this is now the
most common cycle.
You don't do a clean build.
You are in Android Studio.
You say, hey, I
did some changes.
Now, reinstall to my device.
Now the situation is like--
and you only, let's say,
changed a single class.
Still, you have now
no pre-dexing anymore.
So it's twice as fast,
but still 33 seconds.
It's not paradise.
So most of the time is
spent now on dexing.
And then the other
big chunk is install.
And we will continue to work
on making the other bits
before dexing-- all
the stuff Gradle
needs to do before dexing--
configuration time.
This will get faster and
faster, but obviously,
even if we get all the
other stuff down to zero,
75% is still there.
That needs to be addressed.
So not requiring to do a pre-dex
cuts the build time in half.
So as said, it's not
dominated by dexing.
And the problem we have at the
moment is a couple of things.
So first of all,
dexing takes long.
And it's also not
proportional to the numbers
of changes you did.
Whether you change
one file or 100 files,
everything will always be
re-dexed-- your whole code.
So you have a non-incremental,
slow dexing right now.
There's stuff on the
way to improve that.
There's not much Gradle
can do, nothing at
all to make dexing faster.
So the Google
Android platform team
is working on a new indexing
compiler called Jack.
Who has heard about Jack?
So I don't have any deep
knowledge about Jack.
I can only have a look at the
website what they're doing.
The idea is that it consolidates
the source group compilation
and dexing into one step.
So no longer source bytecodes--
Dalvik bytecode-- but directly
from source to Dalvik bytecode.
And Jack has already an
experimental incremental option
that you can use.
So there's serious
efforts happening.
And incremental dexing
plus faster pre-dexing
will lead to
dramatic improvements
of development time.
So I think with a little
bit more patience,
I think things
with significantly
improve when it comes to the
performance of your development
cycles.
What else will the future bring?
I talked about
performance in detail.
For us, this is at the moment,
one of our major R&D efforts.
And so every Gradle
release will be faster.
And with the other
changes I talked
about-- the specific
Android bottlenecks--
when they are gone, you will
have extremely fast Android
builds.
So that day will come.
There is already the new
experimental Gradle Android
plugin out there.
It is based on what we call
the new Gradle model, which
is much, much
faster configuration
time, which will eventually give
you parallel task execution.
So it's still very experimental,
but it's out there.
It's open source.
You can use it to see what
the future will give you,
and the benefits you have
already in this new plugin
are significant
performance-wise.
So the new Android plugin,
just the configuration time
for an Android project
with 10 variants--
with the next generation
Android plugin,
it's already cut down by
a factor of three and more
to come.
OK, extensibility is
already the very strength
of the build platform.
But especially Android is
pushing our extensibility
to a certain degree.
We have the Gradle platform.
We have the Gradle
Android plugin.
We have some Gradle plugin by
some virtual testing provider
in the cloud like Testdroid.
And then we have organizations
that do their own extension.
So when you have this kind
of extension hierarchy,
we now put you
sometimes in a situation
that you need to do
some workarounds to get
the configuration order
right and stuff like that.
So we want even in this very
complex extension scenarios,
we want to provide you a
more solid extension model.
That's something
we are working on.
And even if you don't
use it directly,
you will benefit
from-- the ecosystem
can work better for you.
The other big area we're working
on is dependency management.
So we want to support
fully variant or variant
dependency management so
that you can basically
have Android libraries
and Java libraries that
are aware not just
about their version
but also this debug or
release-type library for NDK.
Is it 64-bit?
Is it 32-bit?
And to make that a
first class citizen when
you do dependency resolution.
That is exciting work.
C, C++ is a very
important platform for us.
We are partnering, for
example, with Unity Technology,
who are migrating the whole
native stack towards Gradle.
And the NDK support, in the new
experimental Android plugin,
will no longer be based on Make,
but on a Gradle C, C++ plugin.
We're very excited about that.
So you will have a similar
rich declarative language
to describe your native
build requirements.
Who of you is
doing any NDK work?
So that should be really nice.
OK so last but not least, we
are releasing a SaaS offering
very soon that allows you
to connect your local or CI
builds, all your Gradle
builds in your organization,
with our SaaS offering.
And this service will help
you with understanding
why something is wrong
with your build or help
a developer to
understand why the build
is not happy with the code--
why the tests are failing
and things like that.
So why is it working locally?
And why is CI failing?
And those kind of questions.
So I'm very excited about that.
If you're interested, please
sign up for the beta wait list.
Hopefully in November, we can
have a full GA of that product.
If you want to
learn more about how
to work with Gradle
for Android, there
is now an excellent
Udacity class online.
It's a Udacity class we
have created together
with Google and Udacity.
It's free if you don't take
it as part of the Android Nano
degree.
I think it's now over 10,000
people that have already
signed up.
It's an old screenshot.
And Udacity is amazing.
Who have you has ever
taken a Udacity class?
I think it's the best online
class experience I ever had.
And this class is
really, really good.
So it might be
interesting for you.
It might be interesting for
some of your colleagues.
It's really good-- perfect
start into Gradle land.
We offer our own trainings.
If you want to get
deeper into Gradle,
we have introductory and
intermediate classes,
but also very advanced classes,
all delivered by Gradle core
engineers, by people that
deeply understand the platform.
OK, that's it.
Thank you.
Any questions?
[APPLAUSE]
Questions?
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: The classes--
are they free?
HANS DOCKTER: No, our
classes are not free.
We are not Google.
So the difference is
they are instructor-led.
So the Udacity class is--
so you can ask questions.
So you get a good
teaching experience,
but you can also ask the
Gradle questions you always
wanted to ask.
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: So I noticed
from the pie chart, about
30% of the cost--
HANS DOCKTER: So please,
can you say it again?
AUDIENCE: So I noticed from the
pie chart about 30% of the cost
is doing the installation
on the handset.
And that's basically
just copying
over files for USB from your
computer over to the handset.
Is there any plan to basically
if your resources don't change,
then just leave them on the
handset and [INAUDIBLE] version
on the handsets.
Because most of our
apps [INAUDIBLE]--
most of the
resources and assets.
HANS DOCKTER: It's a good point.
I understand it.
It's something you would need
to ask the Android Tooling Team.
It's beyond-- it's a good point.
I would ask it on
Android def list
or something like
that, what their
plan-- if there are any plans.
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: I know this is a
read the manual question.
But since you're here--
HANS DOCKTER: Yeah, fair enough.
AUDIENCE: So you were saying,
hey, for the convention,
you know, you had
the sources folder
and you had this and
this because you're
in the Android plugin.
You just know that.
You know ' that's just the
way it is all the time.
HANS DOCKTER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is there a command
line thing where you can say,
oh, I'm using this Gradle
file, and I run this thing,
and it will tell me here's where
the source folder should be.
Here's what this folder or that.
It'll print that out for me?
HANS DOCKTER: Not yet.
But it will be coming.
So it's a very good point.
So just to understand
you-- and the consumers
for that would be new developers
you hire into your team.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, new
developers and also even me,
I'm sitting here,
I'm like, ah, man.
The resource is not RES,
but Android uses RES.
Java uses resources
folder in that area.
HANS DOCKTER: Yes,
it's a good point.
Yes, we understand
that use case,
and we will provide something.
But it's nothing.
Don't read the manual, or
you won't find anything in it
right now.
You find other interesting
stuff in there.
I mean, strictly speaking,
because it's such a rich model,
I'm just saying,
we should do that.
But strictly
speaking, I think it
would take you or someone that
knows a little bit about Gradle
one hour to create a
plugin that would print out
that information on the console.
So at least you could
something about it, right?
Not that we shouldn't do it.
So don't misunderstand that.
But Gradle is so
open and so rich
that you don't need to
create secret master
knowledge to do that.
You could do that in a pretty
straightforward way, actually.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, well, I was
thinking also the plugin says,
oh, this might be called source.
OK, everyone knows
that's a source for Java.
It might be another
folder called RES,
but what's RES used for?
HANS DOCKTER: Yes,
so what you could do,
that is a nice thing
with the rich model.
You could ask the
Gradle Android build
with a Gradle plugin,
hey, what are you--
all those sources are
represented by rich objects.
You can say, hey, main
sources object, please
tell me what is the
path to the Java files?
What is the path to
the resources files?
Because it's all in there.
And then you can print
it out because it's all
richly modeled.
And then, oh, hey,
variant container,
do you have some variants?
Yeah, give me the
variant object.
Hey, free variant, tell
me where are the sources
for the free variant.
Where are the resources.
Where are the integration tests.
So I'm not even exaggerating.
It would be one hour, and
it would be on the console
because it's richly
modeled with them.
It's no magic properties.
That's what we hate.
We hate something, oh,
it just somehow made up,
and there's some magic property
hard-coded in the build script.
No, it's all changeable
and accessible.
But yeah, we should come
with this out of the box.
AUDIENCE: Are we going to do
that at the library today?
HANS DOCKTER: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: Are we going to
do that in code shop today?
HANS DOCKTER: I mean,
my flight is going.
No, I'm seriously
thinking about it.
I'm just thinking
about my schedule.
I might not because I
need to go to the airport.
Maybe.
Let's see.
Maybe I hack it up on
the way back in the plane
and will send you something.
Seriously, we'll see.
AUDIENCE: I would
say that would help.
HANS DOCKTER: Yeah, cool.
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
that we should always upgrade
to the latest Gradle plugin.
I know there's been
compatibility issues
in the past with Android plugin.
You suggested that we use 2.8
right now, which just came out.
HANS DOCKTER: Yes, so I
mean, the big compatibility
issues we had in the
past, and to be fair,
was when the Gradle Android
plugin was 0.something.
So they were deliberately--
they were by design-- I mean,
it was a long period
until we got to 1.0
with the Gradle Android plugin.
But in terms of the
contract, it was OK to break.
But since 1.0 is out, I think
it's extremely compatible
because we are extremely
backwards compatible.
So what they were
doing before 1.0,
they were always-- because
we work closely together,
I just said, oh, to
make this really good,
we need a feature that is
only in Gradle 2.0 or only
in Gradle 2.1.
And so therefore,
it didn't work.
The next version of
the Android plugin
didn't work with an
older version of Gradle
until they have reached 1.0
where they now invest more
into backwards compatibility.
But that was the reason.
Gradle itself is extremely
backwards compatible.
We have a massive test
suite-- 16,000 tests.
And we run it every night
against all different Java
versions and against cross
versions of Gradle testing.
So that's something that people
are usually very happy with.
That is the only reason why
we can't release so often.
Imagine a team like LinkedIn
with 2,000 engineers.
If you break them two
times a year to say,
well, thank you very much,
then they would stop upgrading.
So we can only have
that speed if we have
the quality in that respect.
Yeah.
OK, enjoy the show.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]